so it's saturday of my trip i'm about
halfway through it you might say
um if we cut off the metaphysics
colloquium maybe a third of the way
through it if we include the metaphysics
colloquium which runs till
next thursday
and i am in the institute it turns out
that they
are having a special opening in part
because today is alumni day so there's a
lot of alumni on campus and some of them
are going to visit the library
i'm keeping the door open which is
normally closed and locked for the
the special collections because i think
some of them may come in here i've
already talked with the head librarian
who has informed me
that
people might actually ask me some
questions about what i'm doing and so i
told them i'd be very happy to
talk to them about the the institute
about the special collection even
perhaps you know suggest to them that
they donate because um
money's got to be used for something it
may as well be used for something like
this that really you know benefits
scholarship
and a little bit goes a very long way
when it comes to this compared to other
sorts of enterprises so i'm i'm going to
get some work done on these uh
dissertations
i uploaded a number of photos released
the video from uh from yesterday
and now i'm going to hunker down and get
to what work i can um
partly going through these dissertations
for the the project that they set for me
and partly because of the ones that i'm
particularly interested in that bear on
on research projects
dealing with the ansem that i myself am
writing on like you know the ones that
have to do with the will or justice or
anything like that
so
that's um that's what we've got going on
today
right it's the night of day four i have
been uh getting some productive work
done here in the apartment
you're probably going to hear some noise
coming through because there's people
staying here over alumni weekend you
know alums of saint anselms makes good
sense they had a lot of you know cool
stuff going on for them today
and
i think a lot of these are younger
people
they have a lot of um
uh
tramping and yelling and shouting and
you know laughing and stuff like that
which used to bother me but now i
realize uh since last night it really
doesn't in part i think because i look
back on my own college
years and how how you know i did exactly
the same sort of thing
and didn't really you know what would i
have done if um i knew that there was
some
uh older professor next door
who's a visiting scholar probably not
cared that much and and i i didn't
actually we we probably made life
helpful
the uh the people who were you know
stuck dealing with us so um
in any case
got some good work done today i went uh
to the
library
got some some reading done i actually
had something kind of cool happen i
one of the dissertations that i was
reading was really great and it was by
this guy
um
tareo ferrara um who was a
jesuit
and i wanted to see if he was still
alive
his dissertation was from i think um
1970 something so i thought probably not
you know he'd have to be really young
to to write it then um
turns out actually i found his his
obituary he died in 1987.
61 years old um
and he he was a philosophy teacher he
taught philosophy
at a bunch of different places and then
um went on to earn his his doctorate he
wrote a really great dissertation about
anselm and reason and intellect and you
know all these these sorts of things
um so that was a lot of fun to do that i
spent a lot of the day um
working on on anselm related papers that
i've got going
and managed to bring something that i've
had long hanging for a while to fruition
and get that sent
to somebody did some reading in the st
thomas preparatory for my um working on
my piece on anger and leadership for
this upcoming conference
and now i also did some some some work
on epicurean philosophy got to
read some stuff of philodemus that they
had in the library
um turns out that he he actually wrote
these little short you know
six line sometimes eight line poems a
lot of which had to do with
you know what we might call typical
issues of pleasure for a
a fairly young to middle-aged man
a lot of really cool stuff in in those
and i found one that actually did have
to do with anger so i'm going to
incorporate that into the talk that i'm
working on for next saturday
um
tonight the rest of the night it's nine
o'clock now
uh i think i'm probably going to work
another
hour or two on my presentation for next
saturday i've got my epicurean materials
here
and so i'm going to
flesh out the talk
with the epicurus portions uh and if i
get to it the philidamus portions
the
um
cicero
portions as well which are not actually
cicero so much as people cicero knew the
the
on the ends
and
um
if i can get that done tonight that
means that i can start tomorrow
essentially with a full day
where i've got
a couple projects off the docket
and i don't have to go to the library at
all i don't have to work on the
dissertation stuff at all i can just
focus on the things that i came up here
to to work on
so if i can
get this knocked out that would really
be a great help
so on alumni night they have fireworks
and um
as soon as i heard them i went out to
the parking lot so i could
watch them and
this is uh
what i got to see
nice little display
right now we're getting towards the end
of it
and there were quite a few kids out
there as well all sitting down on the
grass a few
were adventurous and climbed up onto a
container
so here we get some of the the cool
stuff going on
i've always loved fireworks since i was
a kid actually fourth of july used to be
my my favorite holiday i suppose if i
was able to shoot off fireworks it
probably still could be
but i live in a state where we don't
really get to do much of anything and we
only get to watch what other people do
but in any case
here you get to see what i got to see
i'm sharing a little bit of
something that i
really enjoyed with you
and if i'm not mistaken
pretty soon
yeah there we go
we're getting close to the end
this is where they're starting to show
off the really
brilliant stuff
pulling out the stops
all right and now we are actually
gearing up for
every firework show has to have
the
finale there we go
so
all right so happy alumni day saint
anselm college
it's the afternoon of sunday which is
day five of this trip i've been taking
it fairly easy so far today but i've got
quite a bit of work i'm going to have to
do
in a bit so
i
you know slept in a bit
woke up had some breakfast
went to mass up at the uh
the chapel which was very nice um
beautiful chapel by the way i'll see if
i can take some uh some good pictures or
some get some footage of the stained
glass which is something that
always astounds me when i go into it
it's this
in a certain respect non-representative
or non-figurative
stained glass artwork but it's really
quite beautiful and the symbolism built
into it is
is pretty interesting it really works
well as as uh religious art so um
came back down here and then uh called
my wife and we talked for quite a while
then we we actually facetimed because
the animals are missing me we've got two
big and
you know rather old dogs who are kind of
set in their ways and i spend most of my
time
uh working out of our home office
so the dogs are used to me being around
and now
at least one of them is actually
starting to mope quite a bit because you
know i've been i i go on sometimes for
two or three days you know if there's a
conference but not usually this long so
maybe she she thinks i'm you know
totally gone so we facetimed and the
dogs could could hear me i don't know if
they could really see on a screen or not
and they got all worked up and
in any case that took me to the
afternoon and since then i have been
working on what i didn't finish up last
night which is my my presentation on
epicureanism and anger i'm still working
on the notes for that for the talk
coming up
next saturday just seven days from now
and after i finish up with that
um i'm debating about whether i want to
turn my attention to the
thomas aquinas and anger material that
i've got to get
worked up into a decent paper
for the conference that's at the end of
june or whether i want to work on the
gabriel marcel
and christian philosophy debate stuff or
whether i want to work on the saint
anselm and prayer stuff but i think what
i'm going to do is
get done with the epicurean
stuff and
probably go out do a little bit of
last minute shopping
and
then come back here and settle in for a
night of more
work
tomorrow is going to be a very busy day
i've got some interviews scheduled
and
a lot of
work to do in the
the
collection room itself doing the reading
of those
various dissertations i have to start
producing the abstracts now so now it's
really go time
uh so i think i'll devote the morning to
that
and then the the afternoon and the
evening since the library will be open a
bit later i will devote to
my own projects which include the
uh anselm on prayer
paper that i'm working on
um the marcel stuff that i've gathered
some
some work for
um and the thomas aquinas piece so i've
got another two solid days of work after
today before the metaphysics colloquium
begins
and then my time will get really you
know tight here in a good way because
i'll be seeing a lot of old colleagues
and
perhaps meeting a few other new
interesting people it's a chance for me
to find out what's going on in the field
and perhaps make some some decent
contacts you never know hand out some
business cards
what else
that's really about it at this point
so i'll say more after i have gotten
more done
you